MALE SPEAKER: Today we have
Nathalie Cabrol, who's going
to be speaking about her work
around extreme environment
exploration, which I think is
the nice way of saying some of
the most amazing things
that she's done.
She's a pioneer, actually, in
high altitude diving, which is
not like really tall
diving boards.
So if you have a body of water
that's actually at 10,000
feet, to dive in it
is different than
diving, say, in the ocean.
Would that be correct?
Sort of, kind of,
a little bit.
It's complicated
20,000 meters?
NATHALIE CABROL: 20,000 feet.
MALE SPEAKER: Because meters
would be a lot.
I mean I'm American.
NATHALIE CABROL: You'd need
an oxygen tank then.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, you'd
need an oxygen tank.
But she's here to talk about
her work for eventually
exploring the lakes of Titan.
So I'm going to give
it to her.
NATHALIE CABROL: Thank
you very much.
MALE SPEAKER: So join me
in welcoming Nathalie.
NATHALIE CABROL: Good afternoon,
and thank you very
much for the opportunity
talking here at Google.
This is my first time, so I'm
extremely impressed by all the
structures and buildings.
And I mean you have a very, very
cool place around here.
So it's a great pleasure to be
here and to be able to talk
about the Planetary Lake Lander,
which is one of the
projects that we're working on
at Ames, with the Intelligent
Robotics Group.
And the Planetary Lake Lander is
really about developing and
testing a technology that will
be relevant for the future
exploration of alien seas
and lakes on Titan.
But also, it's a mean for
us, because we are doing
astrobiology research to
investigate the impact of the
melting of ice on
our own planet.
And you will see the
relationship between the two.
So basically, we are building
a robot, a smart robot--
at least we hope it
will be smart--
to understand changes
in planetary lakes.
The Planetary Lake Lander
is funded by the NASA
Astrobiology Science
and Technology
for Exploring Planets.
It's a three year project, and
it's a collaboration with a
water company in the Andes.
And I will go back later on why
we are in the Andes for
this project.
And the education and public
outrage is, or maybe should I
say, was supported by NASA.
So we'll see what happens
with that.
PLL is led by the
SETI Institute.
I'm the SETI Institute senior
research scientist, but I'm
also working at NASA through
a cooperative agreement.
So SETI leads the astrobiology
science on the project and the
Intelligent Robotics Group at
Ames leads the technology
development and research
associated with PLL.
And we have a number of partners
in this project.
Some of them are in the United
States and they are working on
instruments and on the science
supporting the project.
The University of Tennessee,
some people at Baylor, the
Channel Islands, so University
of Southern California.
But also partners from Spain,
from Chile, and from Austria.
And we have an incredible
logistical support from people
in Chile and the US as well.
So why Titan?
Well, you've probably heard
a little bit about it.
Titan is a moon of Saturn.
And it's barely smaller
than Mars, actually.
It's a fairly, fairly
big moon.
Just for scale here, here is
Tethys, just a more regular
moon of Saturn.
So it's really more of
a size of a planet.
And what made Titan so
fascinating, it was already
fascinating.
We knew it from the
past mission.
But recently in 2007, the radar
detected the presence of
lakes on Titan.
And so Titan is the only place
in the solar system we know of
that has surface buddies
of fluid.
It's not water, it's
methane and ethane.
But it has a menthanalogical
cycle, like the Earth has an
hydrological cycle.
And so it's a completely new
branch of robotics and
exploration and astrobiology
exploration that we can start
on with Titan.
So the other thing that makes
Titan so very exciting, it's
because pretty much, you can
consider Titan being like a
past Earth in the fridge.
It's extremely cold.
It's very, very far away,
two billion kilometers
away from the sun.
But at the same time, it's the
only other planetary bodies in
the solar system that has an
atmosphere mainly composed of
nitrogen like the Earth.
And the other component is
methane and other moleculing,
including ethane and
other things.
So what we are looking at here
is taking the earth in the
past, but also taking
it in the fridge.
And a number of things happen
in this atmosphere that are
extremely relevant for the
astrobiological search of life
in the solar system and
elsewhere than Earth.
But also understand how life may
have originated, because
we know of a large amount of
organic molecules there.
So what do we don't know of
is did we go from organic
molecule to life on Titan?
And this is probably one of
the best candidate to
go test that idea.
So speaking of the atmosphere of
Titan, now we have Cassini.
Cassini has been orbiting around
Saturn and visiting the
moons of Titan.
We had a flyby only last
week, I think.
Very regularly, Cassini's
passing by, and mapping, and
doing a number of things.
So we've seen that Titan
is very dynamic.
Just like Saturn, because it's
orbiting Saturn, Titan goes
around the sun in
almost 30 years.
So it's a very long year.
Each days of Titan are about
two weeks on Earth.
And the seasons are about
seven year long.
So tell me about having a
crappy winter on Titan.
That must be long.
And so when the seasons
are changing, then
you see clouds forming.
And what you see here on the
screen is the polar vortex
that's forming in the northern
pole of Titan.
Now, what we see from space is
very limited, just because the
atmosphere of Titan is so thick
that we have to use
radar to go through it, a
little bit like Venus.
But we want to round this.
And the landing component of the
Cassini Huygens mission,
actually the Huygens probe
landed on Titan
in January 14, 2005.
And as it went down through
the atmosphere, when the
clouds cleared, this
is what we saw.
And I really love to put this
slide on the wall the time,
because it really looks like
Bay Area when we are coming
back on airplane.
You are landing in Oakland or
in San Francisco, it looks
exactly like that.
So it's a very familiar
landscape,
when you look at it.
And so this was a few thousand
meter above the ground, and
then this is what we saw when
we were on the ground.
And if you are looking on the
upper right of your screen,
you will see that, as we were
descending, we were seeing
dendritic systems that
look pretty much
like rivers on Earth.
So that was very striking.
And once we landed on Titan,
then we discovered what I
immediately say, oh my god,
we are on the beach.
Because what you see is a very
flat piece of land, and you
have very rounded pebbles.
And so Titan is this place that
if you look at, will look
extremely familiar.
You will have rivers, you
will have mountains, and
you will have seas.
And what you see here is not a
landscape on the earth, but
it's actually on Titan.
And what you see is really an
estuary of many rivers coming
into a sea.
But the thing is that it's
really a case of it looks
like, it sounds like, but it's
nothing like the Earth.
Because the rivers are
made of methane.
The rocks that you see around
are made of pure water ice
that is so hard there, because
it's so cold, that these
pieces of ice are being
transported in rivers and
torrents over there.
And they are being eroded
exactly like any type of rock
on earth would be eroded.
So it sounds like home, but you
don't want to be wandering
around without a space suit.
And you definitely are not going
to drink whatever is
running it this stream.
But a very, very interesting,
fascinating world.
So the thing that makes it even
more similar than Earth
than anything else is the fact
that, we have what we call a
methane cycle, exactly like
hydrological cycle I was
talking about earlier on.
So what you have is that
you have bodies of
methane, lakes and seas.
And then you will have
evaporation, and you have
condensation, and then
methane precipitates.
And you have methane
rain on Titan.
And so what happens then is that
in the topography, and
the topography close,
then you will have
accumulation of methane.
And then you will have lakes
forming, ponds forming.
And you can see this in this
image here, where clouds were
captured in the [INAUDIBLE]
region of Titan.
And then, just after the rain,
then you could see the lakes
forming right at the bottom
right of your screen here.
So what is also all very much
like Earth is that lakes will
be filling in, but they also
will be evaporating.
And what you see on the left is
what's happening on Titan
and an analog here on earth.
So it's pretty much looking like
the right foot and the
left foot, but on
the wrong side.
So it's very much something
we can understand.
What we don't understand, what
we don't know of, is really
how the methane chemistry
really works for life.
What kind of word is this for
potential for life and for
habitability?
Here's another picture after 6
year, which is pretty much a
season, showing the changes
in those lakes.
All right, what makes it even
better is that very recently,
we had the high suspicion
that there is a
subsurface ocean on Titan.
So you've heard about
the potential
subsurface ocean on Europa.
You've heard about the pressure
water on Enceladus,
and a number of icy bodies in
the outer solar system.
But on Titan, it's even
more important at say.
Because there is something
really important that we
didn't understand before.
It was that in the methane
cycle, methane is not very
stable at the surface.
And so people wanted to
understand how long those
lakes were going to last, how
they were going to be
replenished.
What is the methane cycle?
And if you have somewhere a sink
of methane, if there is
really an ocean in the
subsurface of Titan, then you
have a mechanism now to
have this cycle that
we are talking about.
MALE SPEAKER: A question
of methane or water?
NATHALIE CABROL: Well, it's
an interesting question.
Because well, in the subsurface
it's probably, most
likely methane, I'd say.
But it will have to have some
ethane components as well,
because we see that in
the surface bodies at
the surface of Titan.
It's a mixture.
Water is not stable
at the surface.
Now what happens at depth, I
just cannot tell you right
now, just like that.
So the evidence for the ocean
on Titan is really tidal.
There is a flexing of the
equatorial bulge as Titan goes
around Saturn.
And this slide is really to
illustrate what I was talking
about, where now you could have
some very interesting
salted ocean underneath the
surface crust at Titan.
And then a way for methane to be
replenished, to circulate,
and go from cycle to cycle.
And those cycles are over
10,000 to 50,000 years.
So this was an important
discovery in terms of
astrobiology.
A cycle of life?
Now, we know that those lakes
and seas may be--
and we don't have a very good
clue about what is the
potential for life in terms of
the chemistry of the methane?
But if there is a place where
life could be protected from
cosmic radiation and from
other extreme of the
environment on Titan, maybe a
body of fluid, just like on
earth, could provide a shield.
So we really need to maintain,
if we want to have life in the
longer term on Titan,
we need to
maintain them at the surface.
And so we have this way where
the methane and the molecules,
the organic molecules that maybe
the bricks of life are
now falling from the
atmosphere into
the lakes and oceans.
And they are being kept there.
And then the oceans and seas
are being replenished.
So it's an interesting potential
cycle that has a
lifetime, as I mentioned before,
of about 50,000 years.
Now I am not a biologist here.
But a microbiologist one day was
asked, what kind of life
can we have on Titan?
And it would be most likely
strange, because we don't know
the chemistry of ethane
and methane.
Smelly, because it's methane.
And we know what methane can
smell here, it's not pretty.
And explosive.
I don't know if it meant by
that that you probably
shouldn't be smoking.
In the first place you shouldn't
be smoking, but if
you have a Titan friend,
it might be a bad idea.
Or just because of the
difference of pressure of the
atmosphere.
The atmosphere of Titan is
1.5 times that of Earth.
And so if you are inviting
that person in your
spacecraft, or kicking out of
the spacecraft, there might be
some problem.
And so in a more serious way,
there is little solubility,
that chemists know, about liquid
methanes, which means
that there will be a lot
of energy spent.
And there is not that
much energy that
is received by Titan.
So what they're thinking is
that if there is life on
Titan, you can have small
things, but you probably won't
have flying dinosaurs.
All right, so that was the
background for why it's very
interesting to go to Titan
from an astrobiological
standpoint.
And so, as soon as the lakes
were discovered on Titan,
somebody who's working with our
team, collaborates on the
PLL project for the past year
now, wrote a proposal, which I
think is the most inspired
project that NASA had in a
very, very long time.
Her vision--
it's Ellen Stofan--
her vision was to send a robotic
platform on Titan at
the surface of the lake and
then let the wind and the
current take over.
And start, for the first time,
exploring an alien sea.
And so they were in a Discovery
program, which is
very limited, has very
little money.
And so they had limited
bandwidth and limited
communication.
So very little data, in fact.
And when I saw that proposal, I
said, it's interesting that
we have a good deal of
experience now with Rover at
the surface of Mars.
We pretty much know
how to do that.
We're improving on this, but
we know how to do that.
But how do you go about
exploring an alien sea?
How do you robotically
do that?
And this was the start of a
thought process that took us a
couple of years to write
the PLL project.
And basically PLL
is about that.
About how do you explore
alien seas and lakes?
You have to explore in a
dynamical environment.
As we saw, there are
precipitation, there is wind.
And you can expect just because
you are in the lake
and there are changes in
temperature on Titan day and
night, et cetera, and season,
you will have stratifications,
changes of the temperature in
your lake during the day or
during the seasons.
And so you will also have
turbidity changes.
Because turbidity is the
murkiness of the water, and
you know that during the
season this changes.
On earth, it changes because
glaciers, for instance, melt.
And as they melt, they
release a lot of
sediment in the water.
And there are other reasons
why you could
have turbidity changes.
You can be an avalanche, there
can be an earthquake, there
can be all sorts of reason.
But when you are on Titan, and
you have that much limited
amount of data and
communication, you will
receive an image now and them.
And you will receive some
data now and then.
How do you put into perspective
what you are seeing?
It's not like on Mars where
you have regular
communication, and you can
have a better idea of
what's going on.
Sometimes you can see things,
you know, data, that you have
no way of putting into
perspective.
So we wanted to address
those questions.
And this was the focus of the
Planetary Lake Lander science.
So now, how do you sail
on an alien lake?
We want to explore the role of
the weather on the lake.
How does weather affect the
lake in terms of surface
temperature, relative humidity,
storms, wind, and waves?
Because this is all
relevant to Titan.
And then how do changes in
temperature affect the
stratification of the lake,
the mixing and the diurnal
cycle between the
day and night?
And also, what is the origin
of those changes?
These are questions we want
to address there too.
And also, what are the triggers
in the change of
turbidity in those lakes?
And also, how do you detect
organics and the lake?
And what are their cycle?
What kind of analogy
do you have between
Titan and the Earth?
So our questions were really,
how can we help
Ellen and the TiME--
Titan Mare Explorer Mission--
to really address the critical
question, to get more science
by being smart, and to put
data into context?
So, now the technology
side of it.
We really want--
because a robot on Titan
will be isolated--
we want to produce a robot that
is smart and that has an
understanding of its
environment.
Basically, PLL is a step towards
robotic awareness.
I told the engineering team that
basically I wanted the
robot to stop short of writing
the science paper.
I want this robot to be able
to understand what is
important for the science
objectives, learn its
environment as it goes during
the mission, knows what is the
norm and what is off norm, and
trigger operation on its own
without having to wait for
human being in the loop
necessarily, if something
happens and they
are not in the loop.
So it's going really
a step forward.
And that requires not only the
body, the robot itself, but it
also requires that you develop
a number of things, including
off board and on board autonomy,
and the development
of what we call adaptive
science.
So basically, a robot that is
aware and that is capable of
making decisions without having
human in the loops.
And one goal as well of PLL
is to develop exploration
strategy templates.
We do that all the
time with Mars.
When you have a specific task
that you do regularly, you
just build a template.
And instead of sending lone
commands, you just send
template number x.
Now, the problem is that we did
not have a very nice body
of methane around here
on Earth to explore.
So we had to work with a working
analogy, and this is
where the deglaciation
thing comes about.
So we want at lake environment
that's capable of helping us
characterize the physical
analogy of the processes that
are going on on Titan, even
if it's not methane.
And we want to understand what
kind of processes will be a
challenge for our exploration.
Also, we need it because this
is a short project.
It's only three years, and we
are looking at deglaciation,
and climate change, et cetera.
You cannot expect to have the
final answer about the causes
and the impact of climate change
in three years, right?
People have been on this
for 40 years now.
So we still want a site where
you have a good deal of change
in the environment.
And very rapidly, so that we
know that the robot is capable
of picking up those changes.
And we also want a science
question relevant to
astrobiology because
this is what we do.
So this is how we ended
up in the Andes.
And we are looking the impact
of the melting ice on the
habitability of lakes
in the Andes.
Global warming is melting
the ice wall.
And as we know, as deglaciation
forms--
well, deglaciation forms
lakes very rapidly--
but the different phases of
deglaciation will do different
things to lakes.
And deglaciation also alters
the temperature of lakes,
their transparency,
habitability, and life.
And this is also the
kind of thing we'll
be looking for Titan.
The reason we are near the
coast in South America is
because we have very high inter
annual fluctuation of
climate and also evolution
of glaciers.
And pretty much it's
unpredictable compared to
other glaciers.
We know that some of them, most
of them, are receding
very, very fast.
A few of them are actually
increasing
in the higher latitude.
And some of those, like in the
Andes, well they are going up
and down because there is this
interaction between global
warming and El Nino.
And they are closer
to the coast.
So they are getting
sometime more
precipitation, sometime less.
And it's evolving very,
very quickly.
And also the reason we wanted
to be in the Andes, it's
because this is probably one
of the places in the world
most affected by
climate change.
But it's a lot less documented
than the
poles and the Himalayas.
All right, here is a little
slide to show you the
glacier we are at.
It's the Echaurren Glacier, and
it's the white line here.
You can see it's evolution.
It's nothing really
very straight.
The trend is down like
everybody else.
But it's going up and down,
and up and down.
And as I said, there is this
conflict between El Nino and
global warming.
So far us, the high variability
of the environment
was really the key to put
a robot up there.
Here's the lake in question.
The lake we're exploring
is Laguna Negra.
It's located 70 kilometers
south of Santiago.
It's not in the high Andes, but
it's in the central Andes
at, say, around 2,700 meter
high, which would be around
9,000 feet elevation.
It's a fantastic site,
as you can see.
It's a very large lake.
It's six kilometer by a little
less than two kilometer wide.
And it was advertised for 12
meter deep when I first saw a
few publication.
We ended up with a body of water
which is 300 meter deep
at our latest bathymetric map.
And so that's a lot of water
column to work with.
And we are really happy
about that.
And it throws at us all kind
of weather, but this is the
joy of working in
the mountain.
Here is to illustrate the
receding of the glacier.
You can see the glacial scarring
on the rocks here on
the lower right in the image.
This is when the glacier
was there.
You can imagine the Echaurren
Glacier actually ended up in
Laguna Negra, and then year
after year receding.
Deglaciation didn't start
yesterday on this glacier.
Started like everything
else in this area,
20,000 years ago.
But it's accelerating very,
very fast right now.
The immense supply from
Echaurren into Laguna Negra
comes through that little
stream here.
And this very nice aqua lake,
which is about 100 and so
meter wide, and that we
call Station Lake.
And there is a very important
reason for that.
It's because we have a
station over there.
It didn't have a name before,
so now it's Station Lake.
But this is really where
the water is
coming into Laguna Negra.
And this is in perspective.
You will recognize the
Google 3D vision of
the area on the right.
No, on the left.
That's the other right.
I was stunned, actually.
Because on the left, this is the
Google 3D of Station Lake
and the water coming in.
As you can see, this is
a hanging valley now.
And so you have a cascade
that links, really, the
stream to the lake.
And you can see a photograph
here of Victoria's Cascade.
This one has a name.
And this is where we want to be,
because this is where the
stream from the glacier
is entering.
And this is where we are going
to see the changes in the
turbidity of the water.
Little bit of touristic
images here.
These are the working tents.
They look very small,
but wait until you
see what we do there.
So these are really big
domes, in fact.
The one on the top left is a
place where we have lunch and
dinner, but it's also
the working room.
And we can fit 30 people
without too
much problem in there.
And now on the upper right and
lower left we have what we
call the RoboDome, where we have
the engineering stations
and the people working there
who are testing PLL.
And on the lower right, we have
the bio dome, where the
microbiologists are doing
their work over there.
So looking at the samples,
et cetera.
So when we are there
it's a little city.
Because we have four of those
domes and then we have about
20 small tents for everybody.
It's a big thing to get there,
about a ton and a half of
equipment and 20 people
last year.
Now, TiME versus PLL.
TiME is the Titan Mare Explorer
Mission of Ellen Stofan.
And PLL, I just wanted to show
you once again the comparison
of the science goal.
So TiME mission on Titan would
go there to understand the
carbon cycle through the study
of the sea and explore the
limit of life.
And our goal is to understand
the impact of deglaciation on
the hydrological and carbon
cycle on this lake.
And also lake habitat
and biodiversity.
What is the impact of
deglaciation on life there?
And then you look at all the
science objectives that are
listed there, and also some
of technology objectives.
And you just basically have to
change methane for water and
sea for lake.
And we're doing pretty
much the same
thing as the TiME mission.
So it's in our chart.
I'm not going to read
through that.
And we talked already
about that.
Now the hardware.
So the TiME Lake Lander mission
is represented here on
the upper left.
And it's a 26 kilogram
spacecraft that has a number
of instrument on board.
And the number correspond
to the names that
I listed down there.
Our puppy here on the right is
about a ton or so, everything
put together.
Liam?
TREY: About that.
NATHALIE CABROL: About
that, about that.
So it's not exactly the same
scale, but this is really the
field horse that we are going
to use to do things.
And there are some
differences.
But there are a lot
of common things.
The numbers you see on the PLL
side are similar in nature
than the number of instruments
that you do see on the TiME
Lake Lander.
We don't have a mass
spectrometer on board.
We have it in the lab, which
means that we need to bring
the samples back.
The same thing for a Raman
spectrometer, which is looking
at organics.
And the thing that we do have
that the TiME Lake Lander
doesn't have is that we have a
profiler, which is basically a
multiparameter sonde that goes
up and down along the winch in
the water and does profile.
Whereas the TiME Lake Lander
will use the propulsion of the
wind and currents to do profiles
at different depths,
depending on the depth
of the lake.
So they are pretty much
passive in the lake.
Whereas right now, we are
more in one place.
This year we'll try to actually
release the Lake
Lander and do profiling
as we go.
But the Lake Lander,
it cannot do that.
Otherwise, we have pretty much
an equivalent payload than the
TiME Lake Lander.
We do also, because we have
some goals that we want to
achieve for the study of the
climate change on Earth, we
have a number of other things
that we do have.
First, we have a shore
station that has--
you see this on the
upper left--
the shore station gives us
some information that are
redundant when it comes to
meteorological information.
We do have a met station on
board the Lake Lander, but
this one is on the shore.
We do have a redundant
multiparameter sonde.
But this one is fixed on the
buoy not too far away from the
Lake Lander.
It's only at one depth.
It doesn't go up and down
in the water column.
But it actually record data at
a much higher resolution.
And we also have another
met station.
And you will understand
why later we
have so many of those.
In the valley, in the
glacial valley.
In this image here in the
middle, at Lake Station we do
have a stream gauge that tells
us everything about the
discharge of the water, the
changes of the water in that
stream, the temperature
of the water.
And this is the instrument
that you see here.
We have GigaPan, which is an
absolutely fantastic camera
that gives us huge,
huge panorama.
Really the kind of thing that
would be really difficult to
get on the TiME mission to
Titan, because you have seven
gigabytes of data to download.
So pretty much, your mission
is right there, one image.
But we use it in many different
ways to survey the
environment, and also to do some
check on the health and
status of the robot.
It takes a picture of itself.
And we do have an underwater
camera that's named The MOC.
And this one is there to survey
what's happening in the
water column right next
to the two PLL.
I'll talk more about
that in a moment.
We do have a few other things.
We're doing some limnology
and ecology, looking at
what's in the water.
Allergies or plankton,
et cetera.
And when really, really we are
bored and don't know what else
to do, we change water, several
bottle, into a little
submersible that we fit with a
GoPro camera, and a few HOBO
data loggers.
And we throw that at
200 meter depth and
try to record something.
The GoPro didn't like
it, but we got data.
I'll show you some.
We also use boats to do the
bathymetry of the lake.
This was something really
important, because bathymetry
is also something that the
TiME mission will do.
So we record that data to be
able to do some operation
readiness test and have a
database we can choose from.
Now comms and data delivery
system for the project.
Here is a little chart
that I prepared.
So on the upper left you see
a satellite that's used.
This is the Earth
orbiting system.
We are monitoring the evolution
of the environment
from the NASA satellite that
are surveying the world.
And this is aqua and terra.
And we are using
ASTER as well.
So this goes directly
on the computer.
You can have access to
that, it's public.
You can work with that.
And we are also using satellites
for communication,
obviously, with the robot.
And there we have
our Lake Lander.
The Lake Lander has different
ways of communicating.
We can communicate with it
through the shore station, and
the shore station can
communicate to the Lake Lander.
And communicating with the
satellite and get comm to the
user at NASA Ames through
satellite comm.
So we have this little relay
going around here.
We can talk or phone
to the robot.
We get data daily and
health status daily.
And then the data, the science
data and the health status
data of the probe is archived
on the xGDS.
And the xGDS is developed
by IRG as well.
And it's what's called the
Exploration Ground Data System.
And it's really a place where
all the data that comes in.
But it's not only a place
where the data
is passively stored.
It's a place where you
can see it live
as the lake is changing.
So you have this vision
of the lake changing.
But there is also a place, the
analysis notebook, where you
can get this data and started
working with the data within
the site itself.
So it's really a tool where
everybody can share the data.
All the scientists can get.
The microbiologist, the
ecologist, the earth scientist
can put their data there, and
people can work with them
within that environment.
And there is also something that
I'm sure Trey will love
to talk more about that later
on, which is this Google Map
vision of [INAUDIBLE].
We developed this bathymetric
map of Laguna Negra, and Trey
already built that.
It's wrapped on the
Google Earth map.
And this is extremely useful
because it allows us now to
not only have those maps, but
when we do samples, have those
samples coregister.
We can go there and really use
them as a working tool.
OK, so now the technology
milestone for the project.
The idea was to develop
this robot.
And in 2011, which was our
first year, it was really
hands on trying to understand
what kind of platform we were
going to use.
And pretty receiving it, and
putting it apart, and trying
to understand how it worked,
what kind of power,
et cetera, et cetera.
And we took Lake Lander for the
first time in the field in
2011, and that was pretty
much debugging time.
For three weeks, four weeks.
And then we left it
in the field.
We have all sorts of
communication problems.
And we swung at that point
that in 2012, we would be
smarter than that.
But we already had a little
bit of data that was very
encouraging.
This year, the engineering team
completely redesigned and
including some recoding
of the probe.
And they did an incredible
job.
And PLL V2 was really
much improved.
It was deployed in Laguna Negra
in December, 2012, and
was put in a permanent mooring
position for all this year, so
that we can collect data
and see what kind of
information we have.
And what is the quality of the
information that we have?
And then we had a little bit
of science and technology
operation from the field.
And Stofan came, and we showed
her how PLL was working.
And we had her coming to some
realization on the few facts,
and I'll show some
of them later on.
And this year XGS came online.
So this is live and the science
team can use it.
It is accessible only by the
science team for the science
data, but we do also have a
website, Planetary Lake Lander
on the SETI Institute website.
All right, a few more photos
to summarize what happened.
On the upper left, you see
pretty much, well, pieces of
equipment in the backyard
at NASA Ames.
And they seem coming together
day after day.
And on the upper right, that
was what we call the splash
down, with the pontoon being
released in the water.
And then on the lower images
are really what happened to
make it happen, which is
calibration of the
multiparameter sonde
really putting
together all the pieces.
And then on the lower right, you
see Liam spending a good
deal of time in the temporary
mooring position, just going
back and forth with the
boat and making sure
this thing was working.
And it did.
December 12 was the day that
I think it went online and
working for the first time.
So that was the day that Lake
Lander was being moved from
the temporary mooring
position.
On the left here, you will see
how much that chair that I
loved really is a very good
analog for planetary
exploration.
On the upper right and lower
right, you see the Lake Lander
being moored in its
final position.
Right here and right here
is the position of
the redundant sonde.
This is what it looks like right
now, except that there
is a lot of snow on top of it.
But you see the instruments
I talked about with the
communication.
The engineering team added a
wind turbine, just because of
the winter.
And because we are in a very
steep valley, which means that
we don't have much sun during
winter over there.
And so we needed some added
on power, and the
wind turbine did that.
And you see the distribution
of the instruments and
communication system
right there.
The MOC cam.
I talked to you a little
bit about that.
We really do want to understand
what's going on in
the water column.
And this is something that you
can imagine can be used to
actually look for microbial
life in the water column.
But it can also be used for
ecological purposes if you are
looking at how turbid
water is.
How murky and what kind of
things are passing through the
water column at different
time of the day.
So Carnegie Mellon is
developing this.
But it's just not a
passive camera.
It's also a camera that is going
to do adaptive science.
And it's actually
going to track
whatever passes in front.
And in this case scenario
here, we
ask it to track copepod.
And copepod is this zooplankton
that you see, the
little red critter on the
upper part of the slide.
So this is pretty much what
happens when they developed
their tracking system.
So this has been developed and
tested this year off board.
And in the coming years, the
camera will be now connected
to PLL and will be watching
what's going on.
And will give us some report
about what's going on in the
water column.
I think this is a really
interesting aspect of adaptive
science where you can get
a lot more information.
Because now your camera
is taking the picture.
It's segmenting that picture,
trying to understand what's
going on in there.
And basically sends you
only the information
that is really important.
So you are not only having the
information, but you are
saving a lot of bandwidth.
Now, for the last part of the
talk I'm going to give some
results about the science, .
and also what is our vision
for 2013 for PLL.
In terms of the deglaciation
here on earth and the causes
of changes in the lake, what
we've seen is that when you
look at the data, you look at
average, it would seem like
nothing is happening on the
glacier at Echaurren.
And that the temperature doesn't
seem to change on
average, et cetera.
But if you are starting to slice
that time into season,
you will see that
something really
interesting is happening.
Summer temperature hasn't
changed that much.
Spring hasn't changed
that much either.
Winter are getting cooler.
But what is changing, really,
is the fall in this area.
And this is the critical point,
because fall is really
the season where snow
is falling.
So two things are happening.
If the temperature is
too warm for snow,
then snow's not falling.
Water is falling, and goes
directly into the lake or into
the water reservoir.
Or if the snow is falling, it's
falling on the ground
that's warmer than
it should be.
So once again, you have more
that goes directly into the
runoff and doesn't go back into
making ice for the lake.
So what you see here, on the
extreme right of the slide, is
to show you the balance
between snow
fall and snow melt.
And this definitely
shows an increase.
There is a lot more melt
happening right now.
So we are looking at this
impact, and also we are trying
to learn, to support a mission
like TiME would be really hard
from space because of the
thick atmosphere.
But here we are doing it
because, once again looking at
the climate change here on
Earth, we understand that
looking at satellite imagery,
and looking at the minerology,
and looking at the thermal
response of the ground, then
you can understand the changes
that are going on.
The thermal imagery is going to
give you some idea of the
size of the grain that
is in your watershed.
So the temperature response of
the ground also depends on the
size of your sediment.
And we see this changing
year after year.
And then you have an idea of
what kind of sediment, and the
size of the sentiment, is
going into the lake.
This is in the watershed.
And so this is going to impact
your life and your
habitability in the
lake as well.
So if we were going to do that
on Titan, we would need to
have an airplane.
We couldn't do that from orbit
just because we cannot see
through it.
But this is definitely using
thermal imagery, is definitely
something that is a tool as well
to understand the causes
of changes in the turbidity
of a lake.
And the nature of the sediments
that's going into it.
In terms of the lake itself and
how you go about sailing a
planetary lake lander on an
alien sea, one very important
parameter is the wind,
of course.
All right, so there are
winds on Titan.
And we know that winds can form
waves when they pass one
meter per second.
And so what we did here was to
study the wind at Laguna
Negra, and try to see
what kind of effect
they had on the lake.
So obviously, one of the first
effect are the waves.
And this lake, which is only 16
kilometer, it's not a sea.
But it's very deep, 300 meter
deep, can generate waves that
are about a foot and
a half in no time.
In no time.
We saw that coming at us in
within minutes, I'd say.
And the weather can change
very rapidly.
So we don't know what will
happen on Titan.
Because at the time where the
mission would be supposed to
land, if it had been selected,
the wind would start to pick
up because of the
seasonal change.
So they would have wave.
But we're not expecting
wave that would be a
foot and a half high.
Still, wind is definitely
something you need to take
into account.
Then you need also
to understand,
what it the lake effect?
If you want to understand Titan,
what is the lake effect
on temperature and relative
humidity?
So we have been studying this
too, and you see this in the
different color line that
are here on this graph.
Now, Trey put this slide
together today, because this
data we received today.
Trey, right?
TREY: Found it yesterday.
NATHALIE CABROL: Found
it yesterday.
OK, so one thing that the Titan
team is aware of is
obviously the role of the
tide because of Titan.
There will be current related
to tides on Titan.
But what they didn't think about
was that the lakes have
oscillation on their own, and
the seas the same thing.
You can generate these
oscillation.
It's just like imagine the
breathing of someone.
OK, you have a wind on the lake,
and then you have a wave
that's carried into that lake.
And the swell will go down
as time goes by.
But there is a rhythm to that,
and there is a cycle.
And we call these seiches.
And you can, theoretically just
with a piece of paper,
knowing the depth of your lake
and knowing it's dimension,
figure out the oscillation, the
wavelength of those seiches.
And we get this little exercise
with [INAUDIBLE]
because we thought we
were seeing some.
And we changed the data
resolution on
our water level sensor.
And this is what we picked up.
So there are seiches.
And the period is about
30 minutes.
We would have to know much
better the depth of the sea or
the lake where Titan robot needs
to go if we wanted to
understand what is the
oscillation and the wavelength
of a seiche.
But they will have also to
figure out a way to work with
those, because it depends
on the wind, depends
on a number of things.
But definitely, this will take
their robot from one
place to the next.
Bathymetry.
This is one point where
definitely Ellen came to some
very, very hard realization.
So the idea is that, as the
TiME robot lands or splash
down on the lake, it
will use the wind.
There is no propulsion.
There is also no way
of stopping it.
It's just a passive robot
going on the lake.
And every hour or so, it says
a ping with the sonar to do
the bathymetry of the lake.
So 8:00 in the morning, we
take Ellen on our boat.
We have the bathymetric system
on, and we sit in the middle
of the lake.
And say OK, let's be the probe
and see what happens.
One hour later we were about the
same place because there
was no wind.
So I said to Ellen, two things
are going to happen here.
If you don't have any wind,
you will have a very, very
high resolution map of
your lake from a
very, very small area.
But if you have lots of wind,
you are going to have a very
low resolution map
of your lake.
So these are the kind of thing
that all of a sudden
operationally you start
to understand.
If you have a passive robot,
it's not going
to be a simple thing.
And also, if you are passive and
if there is an obstacle,
you're doomed.
So these were the kind of
rational and reasoning we went
through with her over there.
All of a sudden, this mission
to the different life.
And for us too, because we
didn't know what exploring
alien seas and lake
was going to be.
So, in terms of the lake itself
and what's going on
here, I'm not expecting this to
happen on Titan, but just
because it's so incredible.
As deglaciation progresses,
lakes are becoming more
transparent, at least at
one phase of them.
And this is a disaster
for life in there.
Because for the first phase,
when the lake is turbid, you
have plenty of microbes
in there.
There's a large biodiversity,
everything
and anyone is there.
But one, the transparency
changes and increases.
All of a sudden, the UV goes
through the water column.
And whatever is not resistant
to it gets fried.
So those lakes still have lots
of population when you are
looking at numbers, but the
biodiversity is going down.
And you now have microorganisms
that are
resistant to UV.
What you see here to the
left is the water
column of Laguna Negra.
And this is taken at
a time where the
lake is at the murkiest.
So there's a spring, summer.
And we still had light a 50
meter down, which means that
this is probably, if we were
going to have the same data in
the winter, it's going to be
even more transparent because
all of the turbidity and the
sediment has settled down.
So you see the curves
right there.
That probably puts this lake
as one of the highest, most
transparent lakes
in the world.
And you can still see the curve
changes in light at the
bottom of the lake.
And this is 45 meters down.
So what life does, it
follows the food.
And so we hope that on
Titan it will be
doing the same thing.
What you see on the left here
are two charts showing the
changes in chlorophyll and blue
and green algae in the
water column.
One is really somewhere in the
middle of the lake at the
temporary mooring station.
And at the permanent station
here, where the cascade is and
where the nutrients are being
brought into the lake, this is
where you get most of the
chlorophyll and the blue and
green algae.
Now, adaptive science.
What you see here--
and that will be the conclusive
part of the talk--
is some of the profile that we
are getting from the Planetary
Lake Lander.
And typically, this is the kind
of thing we would love to
have on Titan.
And what the robot is going to
do is to be able to learn the
changes that you are seeing
in the water column.
Here you have temperature, you
have transparency, you have
dissolved oxygen, and you
have chlorophyll.
And so what it does, it's
picking up the changes in this
environment.
And what we want it to do is
really to try to understand
what's going on, what is the
cause of the change?
And this is the adaptive system
that we were trying to
develop here.
So what I put here in that box
is a change in turbidity
that's related to a change
in temperature.
And now we are going back to
what I was saying at the very
beginning of the talk, is that
why is it important for us to
be able to pick up changes in
temperature and turbidity?
Because these are the kind of
changes we are going to pick
up on Titan as well.
And we want to understand
what they are.
So basically, when you have
changes in turbidity in a
lake, because it's seasonal,
you will have a very slow
gradient of turbidity
going up.
If this is something that's
related to a stochastic event,
such as an avalanche, your
signal is going to have a very
different gradient and go down
in a very different way.
And you can have also algal
blooms and things like that
increasing your turbidity.
So what we want to do this year
really is to teach PLL
how to recognize those.
And once we have the algorithm
ready for that, then we will
try this inside over there.
And hopefully we can make
some demonstration.
This is really the goal that
we have this year.
So 2013 will be really our
testing time for PLL.
We will have a robot, hopefully,
that we can release
in the lake.
We will be able to drift like
it would do on Titan.
And also be able to pick up
changes in the environment,
and tell us what kind of
changes these are.
So I'm going to go through
this very quickly, but
basically this is what the
robot has to learn.
It has to learn how to
recognize changes in
temperature, in turbidity, in
water discharges, and in water
temperature.
And changes in chlorophyll
and blue green algae.
Put that together, and then
come up with the right
solution in telling
us what it was.
And finally, this is our
timeline for this year, the
field campaign.
And the field campaign
will be in December.
And we will have ORTs this
summer and beginning of fall,
and working with the TiME
mission as well, to give them
some data to think more about
a real mission to Titan.
So thank you very much.
I'm running over, I'm
sorry about that.
But this is what PLL is about.
There's still a lot
for us to learn.
But definitely, exporting lakes
and alien seas is a
very, very different beast.
I'm coming from the Rover
standpoint and exploring Mars.
And it's completely different.
It's completely different
because you don't have as much
command over your robots.
It's not that you can drive it
at this point in time if we
are going with a concept
of time.
But maybe the lesson that we
have is there are some flaws
in that mission concept that
we want to change, because
going to another
planet is hard.
When you're succeeding in
landing there, I think you
should be able to steer a little
bit your robot if you
feel that there is a danger
somewhere coming at you.
So anyways, thank you very
much for your attention.
And just as the last slide,
here's the crew
of the pirate ship.
MALE SPEAKER: So we're
all pretty
interested in bandwidth.
We think in huge bandwidth
numbers here.
And you talked about having
really low bandwidth
allotments, and presumably
low computational
allotments as well.
Can you talk about why that's
a hard constraint?
That you can't just be like,
actually you know what, it's
worth it to get more
bandwidth back.
So let's spend a little more
money on better rockets.
NATHALIE CABROL: Well it's
not like the rocket.
And there are a number thing I
want to be very candid with
you on this.
I will not talk about the TiME
specs, because this is
proprietary material from Ellen
and I. I swore to her
that I wouldn't talk
about that.
But I can give you an idea
of why the limitation
are what they are.
This mission was proposed
in the context of
the Discovery program.
And then you have that much
money that you are allotted.
And this is why they
don't have an
orbiter supporting them.
And this is why they have to
go, they had to go now,
because of a direct worth
that they can use.
They are in line of sight.
The season is going to change
very, very fast on Titan.
And so it's going to be a lot
more complicated even, to
communicate.
But you have the constraints
that are related to a program.
But now if you want to say,
OK, let's assume that the
program is not the constraints,
how would I do that?
Well, sure.
You wouldn't like to
limit yourself.
Once you're on Titan and you
land there, you want as much
information as you can.
And you don't want to have one
image per day, per Titan day.
And so on and so forth.
So how you do that?
Well, you can put small orbiters
or communication
satellites, you know, swarms.
We do little things now that are
not so expensive anymore.
But it's not going
to be within the
Discovery Program frame.
Although, the Discovery
Program is going to be
recompeted soon now.
So we'll see if Ellen goes.
If she doesn't, then
maybe there are
room for other options.
And who knows.
The private sector seems to be
very keen on getting involved
into planetary mission.
And when you look at
the cost of that, I
think it's very feasible.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm
just wondering,
have you worked with--
well, was there any idea to have
a Rover right by the edge
of the lake that could
also go in?
NATHALIE CABROL: Definitely not
in a Discovery Program.
But what we did that is not in
the TiME mission, the shore
station that we do have is
already a relay showing us the
perspective of what's over there
on our shore, not on
Titan, all right?
But it's looking also at the
Lake Lander, the Lake Lander
is looking at it.
So we have ways of seeing what's
going on on the shore,
seeing the changes.
Now you are talking about an
integrated mission that will
have a Rover and
a Lake Lander.
And in that say, if you go that
route, why don't you put
an airplane on Titan?
Or a balloon?
And I'm just half kidding,
because this is exactly the
place where you want
to do that.
And I was talking about the
thermal imagery that we are
using to survey the watershed
and the meteorologist changes.
But then you can think about
having those instruments on
board two little airplanes,
or one airplane.
And following the Lake Lander,
and just looking
maybe what's ahead.
Because you don't have this
vision from the Lake Lander.
Maybe you can have it as a scout
for your Lake Lander.
You will more or less know where
you are going because of
the direction of the wind.
And so maybe an airplane can
go there and send you data,
and allow you to do
some planning.
A little bit like what we do on
Mars when we are using the
orbiter to plan traverses or we
are using panoramic images.
But when you are on the water,
there is more water or methane
in front of you.
So this is hard.
But no, it's very interesting.
I'm completely sold to the
ideal of multirobotic
approaches even on
one mission.
Swarms of robots are really
good ideas, but they can
become very expensive and very
complex, very, very quickly.
MALE SPEAKER: I was wondering,
how much do you know about how
the oceans behave there?
Or these lakes, how strong
are the currents?
And also, the differences
between floating in water and
floating in methane?
People think the density
is different.
NATHALIE CABROL: Yeah, the
density of methane is about
half that of the water.
So you're going to float.
But for the ways right now, the
seasons they were supposed
to land on, winds were supposed
to get up to one
meter to 1.5 meter.
This is what's modeled.
And once again, once you land,
you learn where your model
went wrong.
But this is what
it is modeled.
And so this is going to
generate small waves.
We're not expecting anything
like a tsunami.
But anything can happen.
I mean, large waves are
happening in lakes, not only
because of wind, but they're
also happening because rocks
fall into the water.
You can generate very large
waves because of that.
On Titan there is less risk to
have asteroids and comets
falling and generating
a big wave.
But that can happen.
We saw that the frequency on
Mars is quite abundant.
Did you see the paper a couple
of days ago coming out?
So new you impact
craters on Mars.
This is not going to
happen on Titan.
The atmosphere is thicker
than it is on the earth.
But things happen,
things happen.
So you can have a large waves.
So winds, one to 1.5
meter expected.
Waves at say, about 10,
20 centimeter max.
So it should be a smooth
ride to some extent.
And the currents are being
generated by the wind, also by
the seiches I talked
about, but also by
Saturn's tide, daily.
And I don't remember the number
of all the tides.
I don't know if you have
any idea, Liam.
I don't remember.
But they are a few meters
per second.
FEMALE SPEAKER: How do
you determine that
what you see is life?
NATHALIE CABROL:
Great question.
Well if you have a rabbit
jumping in front of the--
that's always the response.
But we're not expecting
a rabbit on Titan.
But, as I said, once you land,
this is when you know where
you went wrong.
But more seriously, I think that
in the incarnation events
vision of exploration of Titan,
time is a first step.
It's not a life detection
mission, but definitely they
are looking at organics.
So they are looking with a Raman
at organic molecule that
they can find.
And their abundance
in the water.
And the changes of this
abundance during the day,
during season.
Well, they won't
last that long.
So in the course of the day and
night, the same thing as
you would do on the Earth
that we are surveying.
So they will be measuring
that.
Once again, it will be
very, very limited.
And this is always unfortunately
the same theme
that comes back with
the TiME mission.
Not because it's a bad mission,
but because it's very
limited when it comes
to what they can do.
But the power of it is that
it's the first time.
This is the first data
we're going to get.
And with that data,
we are going to
prepare something else.
Remember the old
Viking mission?
Viking mission to Mars had a
life experiment on board.
And we went with a life
experiment on Mars.
And then we landed there for the
first, and we had no clue
what the environment was.
And then when it came time to
really interpret that data, it
was really hard.
Today we still say the results
were ambiguous.
But now we know that there are
number of things that can
create the result that we
saw that are not life.
So the idea is, you just cannot
go to a place that is
so completely different
than our place.
And Mars was so close
compared to that.
So methane chemistry?
I have no clue.
So the only way I think we will
know that something is
alive in front of a camera if
it's jumping out of the water
or moving in certain direction
that mean that they are not
only driven by currents and by
other things, but right now,
TiME is not a life
seeking mission.
It's a brick of life-- a little
bit like Curiosity.
Curiosity is looking right now--
it's not a mission that
searches for life on Mars.
It's a mission that's here to
say, where the bricks of life
present on Mars?
So a mission like TiME
would do that.
And I think this is a very
wise first step.
MALE SPEAKER: So it kind of blew
my mind when you started
by saying, yeah, let's try
just letting a drift.
Right at the beginning.
I'm thinking, oh well I put a
robot on a lake, and in not
very long I've got
a broken rowboat.
And I didn't go where--
NATHALIE CABROL: This is exactly
what I'm saying.
But I'm here to make
his life miserable.
MALE SPEAKER: So can
you talk about the
practicality of that?
And why it's a less
bad idea than it
sounds to my naive mind?
NATHALIE CABROL: Oh it's a worse
idea than whatever you
have in mind.
MALE SPEAKER: It's
a worse idea than
even I could imagine.
NATHALIE CABROL: But I'm
conscious about that.
I don't ignore it.
And I'm not completely
stupid either.
So us here is the idea.
We definitely have to
demonstrate that we can do the
kind of science that
we have developed.
Because developing adaptive
science on a platform that's
not moving, that's anchored,
then you have sort of a stable
environment.
The lake is what it is
around your robot.
And then you pick up stuff
and it changes.
And you know it changes because
you are in one place.
But now what we are saying is
that we are going to send the
robots, floating robots
on Titan, the
thing is going to drift.
Because this is what they
had in their scenario,
it is going to drift.
So now we need to demonstrate
that we can do that kind of
adaptive science and pick up
real changes as we go.
Which means that not only we
have a floating robot, but
then we have to understand that
the changes that we're
seeing are not only related to
the different places where we
go, but also to something
fundamentally important for
the mission.
This is very, very complex.
Because as you move across the
lake, you are changing
environment.
And condition might change.
And you might trigger your
adaptive system all the time.
We have no clue about that.
Once again, we are going
to be hands on there.
And this is scary.
This is scary from the
adaptive standpoint.
But this is also scary from
the robotic standpoint.
And the good thing is here on
Earth, we can do something.
And the thing we're going to
do is to put a couple of
engines on board the platform.
And probably someone on
the platform as well.
Which means that we will do this
when conditions are OK.
And so there is a lot of
wind on that lake.
But we know the time during
the day where
there is less wind.
So we'll do operations
at that moment.
I don't even want to think about
starting to talk about
night operation to the safety
review board at Ames.
But it ultimately, we'll have
to go there at some point.
And so if something, if there
was a realization to me the
first day we put PLL in the
water was that going to Titan
pretty much dead in the
water is a bad idea.
And so if there is something
that needs to be changed in my
mind, it's that this robot
should have some mode of
propulsion.
If only an emergency one.
And one that you don't want
to use all the time.
MALE SPEAKER: That's really
scary looking rock.
Maybe we use up some
battery power.
That kind of situ-- right?
NATHALIE CABROL: Yeah, and for
that, you also need more
bandwidth, because you need to
be able to see that rock long
before it hurts you.
And in the kind of bandwidth
and capabilities they have,
I'm not sure we can
do that really.
And that goes back to the
airplane or whatnot--
a surveyor on top of you which
could help you this way.
So I really love the TiME
mission, because it is the
first vision of an exploration
of an alien sea.
By many means, it is a poetic,
more than scientific, vision
of exploring seas, just like we
did in the past, where you
were putting a boat with
people on the sea.
And let's go.
Let's go see what's
in front of us.
And we'll see.
But in the meantime, it takes
a long time to get to Titan.
It is scary to be going through
that atmosphere and
splash down.
And you want the
most out of it.
You really want the
So if Ellen is going to
resubmit, I think I would have
a few suggestions for her.
And if I was going to submit a
mission, it would definitely
have some different
flavor about it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]